[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAMIAN LAWLOR: Well, thank
you very much for turning up
at 9 o'clock.
I'm Damian Lowlor.
I'm the managing
director at Google Cloud.
I'm here to talk
to you about how
to build top notch marketing
technology at scale.
A little bit about myself.
I am almost 11 years in Google.
I spent two years running our
publisher network in Europe,
then six years running our
DoubleClick ad technology
in Europe.
And I've been 2 and
1/2 years in Cloud.
I'd love to get an idea
about who is in the room.
How many of you are actually
building marketing technology
that you sell as a SAS solution?
OK, that's about
half of the room.
How many of you build
marketing technology
within an enterprise for
a marketing department
or to support a
marketing department?
OK.
And how many of you are
users of marketing technology
yourselves?
Anyone in the wrong session?
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, that's the first
time somebody's
actually answered that question.
Good man.
So this is a really,
really exciting space.
The number of AdTech
and MarTech companies--
we talked to either
Chief MarTech or to LUMA.
You know the famous
LUMAscape that
is getting, as more and
more companies get launched,
the size of everybody's logo
gets smaller and smaller.
But Chief MarTech
actually very helpfully
provided Google Doc with all
of the names of the companies
that they actually list in
their impossible-to-read poster.
And its over 10,000 marketing
and advertising technology
companies that they
have now identified
in the space, which is pretty
amazing how much growth we're
seeing in this area.
And it's no surprise
because we're still
trying to solve those
fundamental opportunities
and challenges that
all of marketers have,
like how can we understand our
customers better and really
personalize their experiences.
How can we measure better
across all channels
and drive really,
really excellent RLI?
And how can we unlock the
creativity of our teams,
so instead of them having
day-to-day work that doesn't
drive a lot of value,
like free them up
to really be able to
do at top value work?
And then, of course, you've
got so many different changes
in the environment.
You've got the
huge shifts we saw
over the last years in consumer
behavior towards mobile.
And of course, now
everybody wants
to see how they can
use machine learning
to really drive efficiency,
effectiveness, and value.
And this is only
getting more important,
I think, for the enterprise.
This is a pretty
amazing stat that 22%
of a company's marketing
budget is actually
spent on technology.
And from all of the
analysts I talk to,
I think this number will only
go up because of the promise
that marketing technology
holds for everybody.
There's a really
fascinating set of trends
happening about
how CMOs, and CTOs,
and CIOs, how that
is converging.
There's another stat about how
CMOs are actually controlling
more and more of an
enterprise's technology budget
because the enterprise sees how
this technology can actually
drive top line revenue and
growth for the company.
So that's very, very interesting
to us here at Google Cloud.
Obviously, not only are we
talking to CTOs and CIOs,
but we're now actually looking
to talk to the business line
folks and show how Google
Cloud can drive real business
impact for them.
So here are some of the
opportunities and challenges
that we hear from
people like you
that we need to address when
we're thinking about building
marketing technology.
So obviously, creating
tools to allow
marketers, your customers,
to meet their needs.
And we hear a lot about people
wanting to leverage machine
learning, how to
make sense of it,
and how to take action on it.
And unlocking innovation
throughout your organization--
I think that's a
really important part
to think of is how do you
make things easier and faster
for the people that are actually
using the tools so that they
can focus on what
every CEO wants,
which is focus on driving
growth and driving revenue.
So as competition increases, so
both for people in the room who
are building marketing
technology tools that you sell
as a SAS solution, or people
who are building tools
and technology
within a business,
you're all focused on
wanting to drive innovation
and differentiation
for your customers,
be they internal or external.
And the sophistication of those
solutions is only growing.
So how can we help?
So first of all, in
my journey to Cloud,
one of the things
that attracted me
to Cloud after eight years
working on the MarTech
and AdTech side of the
business in Google was I
had a hypothesis--
think about what
Google Cloud is.
It's the externalization
of the technology
that we use to drive the largest
search and digital marketing
company on the planet.
So I wondered, would
that technology
be really good at solving
marketing technology
and marketing
analytics problems,
considering it was actually
built for a marketing
technology company?
I think that the
answer is best answered
by people like yourselves.
But in working with well over
100 companies over the last two
years, I think we've been
able to see really, really
clear examples of where
Google Cloud really
does excel in this particular
space because of the way
our cloud was built, but also
because of our deep domain
knowledge within marketing.
We have over seven
products that have
over a billion monthly
active users on our platform.
And this has really
helped us to understand
the type of innovation,
scaling, security issues
that you're facing every day.
And we want to help
that infrastructure
that we built really
support you in your goals
and what you're
looking to build.
So let's talk about three
different areas where
we think we can really help that
we stand out in-- so developing
features and products faster,
helping you to scale globally,
and efficient pricing.
Let's start off with feature
and product development first.
Let's talk about MainAd.
I'm actually going to talk
through some customer examples
here rather than just talking
about conceptually how
Google can help you.
So MainAd is a real-time bidding
and programmatic ad retargeting
company.
They were originally running
at about 50,000 requests
per second, but they
recognized that they
needed to grow faster.
And in moving to Google
Cloud, the important part
was actually the impact
on their business outcome.
They were actually able to
improve their bidding accuracy
by 75%.
And obviously, being a
performance management company,
a performance
marketing company, that
made a huge difference
to both what
they were able to provide
to their customers,
and also their own
business outcomes.
They launched a new
platform on Google Cloud
and focused on AI
machine learning.
And in doing that,
they were able to apply
real-time predictive
analytics to ad retargeting.
And again, very, very
significant impact on their
conversions, which is a big part
of their business, a big part
of their growth, and
how to make money
for themselves and
for their customers.
In terms of scaling globally, I
have, on a number of occasions,
actually shared this data with
Dan from Infectious Media.
And I think his story
is pretty fantastic.
He pretty gleefully
talks about the fact
that he originally built the
technology infrastructure
on a different cloud and
then just could not scale,
and actually made the decision
that I haven't come across,
actually, that I'll
just asked the audience.
He actually moved from
Cloud back to on prem
in order to be able to deal with
some of the performance issues
he was seeing.
And I'm just asking, has
anyone else done that?
Have you moved from
Cloud back to on prem?
It's not a direction we
see a lot of people go.
Oh, OK.
He explained the logic
of it in terms of he
did actually solve his
performance problem,
but all that happened
was that he then
had a gigantic scaling problem.
The scaling problem was that his
costs started scaling linearly
back when he was on prem.
So he actually hit a point
where they really wanted
to launch in APAC, in Asia.
And they knew that was going
to be a huge, huge growth
in their business.
They were caught in this dilemma
of whether they were going
to launch on prem and then
migrate to Google Cloud,
or whether they would
actually move to Google Cloud
and then launch.
But they knew that there
was a huge amount of revenue
and business that they'd lose if
they either made a mess of it,
or if they delayed too long.
So we were able to convince
them that they could actually
do both in a very, very
short period of time.
And it went very,
very well for them.
They actually migrated their
entire business in a week
with no downtime,
then launched in APAC,
which quadrupled their business.
And one of the most
amazing stats about that
is that at 4x the size--
so they went from 35,000
transactions per second
to four times that
after launch in APAC--
their cost base
remained the same
compared to what
they'd been on prem.
So they were
absolutely delighted
with both the performance,
the scalability, and the cost.
So actually, and
that's the next area
that I want to talk
about, efficient pricing.
So moving to the cloud is
not all about saving money.
But we do recognize
that efficient pricing
is a very, very important
part of your business model.
And we want to think
of it in terms of,
by providing efficient
pricing that you only
pay for what you use, that
gives you more resource that you
can reinvest in your business
and reinvest in growth.
So Knorex, also a programmatic
advertising platform,
also totally focused on
scalability and speed,
and they wanted to build
out their real-time bidding
functionality powered
by machine learning.
Here, they did.
They moved across, and they
got an immediate 30% reduction
in cost, which they were
then able to reinvest
in the growth of their business.
They actually said that,
although that was great,
that one-time cost
reduction was fantastic,
what they appreciated even
more was their freeing up
their precious developer
resources from doing
operational tasks and
getting them to actually
be able to develop the tools
and the technologies that
were actually going
to drive growth
and revenue for their business.
So it's the
combination, I think,
of the freeing of resources that
losing the opportunity costs.
And then, of course, there
is a cost-benefit, obviously,
of moving to the cloud.
So what does this mean
for your business?
So we've built our cloud
to be hyper-efficient,
very security conscious,
scalable for ourselves.
And we now want to
bring that to you
and help you transform
the way you can build
your own marketing technology.
So at this stage, I'd like to
invoice my good friend, Sudhir
Hasbe, who's the PM director
for data analytics to the stage,
to go even deeper
on what we can do
to help you to build a top
notch marketing technology.
Thanks, Sudhir.
SUDHIR HASBE: Thanks, Damian.
[APPLAUSE]
So as Damian said, I
am director of product
for data analytics at Google.
I've been here
around nine months.
Prior to this, I was VP
of engineering at Zulily.
I built all the data
platforms there.
I owned ad tech, merchandizing
tech, product pricing,
all of that stuff.
And I built all of that over
3 and 1/2 years at Zulily.
So I'm happy to share some of
the experiences from my past
as part of this session.
But before that, let's actually
go and talk about Google Cloud,
and what are the key areas
that we try to go in and help
our customers.
One is, the whole
marketing tech is
all about big data,
massive amounts of data
that you can collect, leveraging
that data to do better
segmentation to target
the right customers,
reducing your total cost
of acquiring customers,
getting a better
return on investment.
So solid on data analytics is
all about machine learning.
And I fundamentally believe
that we have the best technology
for those things in the world.
The other thing is
being open and having
an open-source-based technology,
or being an open cloud
is super critical,
because all customers
do want a solution that can
run in multiple environments.
Right?
Most of our customers are
in a hybrid environment,
especially with on premises
in Cloud, or on GCP.
Some of them are across
multiple different clouds.
So it's important
to have technologies
that can actually span between
different environments.
And then, of course, one of
our key differentiators--
we don't talk much about it, but
one of our key differentiators,
I fundamentally believe,
is our global network.
The reach that we
have with our network
is pretty amazing in
every part of the world.
And we'll see a bit of that.
But before that, let's talk
about the data analytics.
We are a data company.
Fundamentally, the whole
Google, as a company,
we collect massive
amounts of data.
We process that data.
We analyze it.
And we've built some
amazing products.
Damian was saying we
have seven products that
are billion-plus active users.
We are actually
going to be roughly--
I think eighth one is coming, I
heard earlier in the keynotes,
with the Drive Enterprise
maybe reaching billion users.
So that's what we do.
We understand users.
We understand what they need.
And we build better
products for them.
And so big data is in our DNA.
One of the other key
learnings that I have--
and this is one of things.
I think "Forbes" or somebody
had the article on this is,
if your company is
not good at analytics,
you are never going
to be good at AI.
So fundamentally, the
first thing I always say
is, get better at
core analytics.
Get better at having good data.
And then you'll be able
to do machine learning
pretty easily on top of that.
And one of the things
that we are doing
is trying to get the
machine learning tools,
make it easier and easier
for our audience to use them
and leverage them
for solving problems.
And I will touch
upon a couple of them
this week that we have launched.
But from a core
platform perspective,
what we are trying
to do is four things.
One, we want you to
focus on analytics, not
on infrastructure.
So if you look at some of our
products that we are building,
they're all serverless.
So you can literally
bring your data in,
you can start analyzing,
start doing segmentation,
start doing targeting,
just based on the data
that you have.
So you don't need skills--
you don't have to worry
about monitoring products.
You don't have to
worry about managing,
scaling infrastructures.
That's our problem.
We will take care of that.
The second thing is
comprehensive solutions.
And I'll touch upon the whole
portfolio of products we have
and how they fit into what you
can do with marketing tech.
I will touch upon
that more details.
We have an end-to-end
machine learning lifecycle.
So if you think about
it, 80% of the time
our data scientists and analysts
spent on is cleaning data.
And 20% goes into actually doing
real analytics or real machine
learning stuff.
So we're trying to
build tools that
are making it easy for you to go
do that, that whole lifecycle.
And then, of course, innovation.
We're innovating faster.
We're delivering newer
and newer products.
So this is a whole
portfolio of products.
I won't go into everything here.
The key point I wanted
to make in this one
is, if you wanted to collect
time real-time events globally,
wherever your
customers are, and then
you want to take those events
as soon as a person comes
onto your website, on
your mobile device,
and you want to do a targeted
offer for them or something,
we have products
across the board.
So if you see
Cloud Pub/Sub, it's
a globally scalable
event collection system
where any kind of clickstream,
or event, or something,
you can just collect
and then take action on.
Dataflow, Dataproc, they're
large scale data processing
solutions, where you
can get those events
in real-time figures.
I will give you a real example.
At Zulily, we did this.
Every time first people
came into the website,
we collected those events and
clickstream, collected them
into a messaging system,
real-time aggregated
that information, and
just showed it back.
You see this on different
hotel sites and all.
n number of people are
watching this room right now,
or y a number of people
are buying this stuff now.
We just did that.
It took us a couple of weeks
because that all pipelines were
already in place.
Immediate uplifting of
our conversion rates,
because that's an instant
feedback for customers
what they are doing.
So those kind of
systems are really
easy to build with things like
Pub/Sub, Dataflow, Dataproc.
And then BigQuery is a
large-scale data warehouse.
I'll talk more about it.
It allows you to go ahead and
collect large amounts of data,
and actually process it, and
do segmentation and things
like that.
And then if you want to get
into advanced analytics,
you can use ML Engine,
TensorFlow for real machine
learning at scale.
Here's our database
portfolio again.
I'm not going to do a lot of
talk on specific products.
But the most important
thing, I would say,
is, as I said, BigQuery,
large-scale data
analytics you can do in that.
The other side of
things is if you're
looking for a globally scalable
relational database which
can be consistent across the
globe for your transactions,
Spanner is the solution.
Spanner can scale globally.
A lot of our internal
systems actually
leverage Spanner for the
consistency across the globe.
So that's one of the products
that you should absolutely
look at.
But let's talk about
BigQuery for a second
because that's where we
have key innovations.
So a lot of internal analytics
that we run in Google
all runs on something
called Dremel.
There is a Dremel
paper externally.
BigQuery is an externalization
of the same technology.
So first of all, you will use
the same petabyte-scale Cloud
scale data warehouse
that we internally
use for all our analytics, you
will use in your enterprise.
So that's one key thing.
The second key thing here
is, it's highly secure.
It allows you to do
real-time streaming directly
into the data warehouse.
So you can collect events,
and at the same time,
ingest it directly
into the warehouse,
and do real-time analysis.
Somebody checks into
the hotel, and you
want an analyst to
know that instantly
within under a second.
You can collect that, put it
into BigQuery, know what it is,
and take actions on it.
So those are the
kind of scenarios
you can enable with this.
Fully managed and
supports standard SQL.
So most of your analysts
would know some form of SQL.
And if they can use SQL
for general analytics,
BigQuery is very easily
available for that.
One of the things in
BigQuery we have done
is making it really easy for
you to get your advertising
information data from
different ad channels and all,
especially with Google,
easily into BigQuery.
For example, most
of our customers
already use Google tech,
AdWords, DoubleClick, YouTube,
Play Store, all of
these different things
for advertising.
All that data,
with a few clicks,
you can literally
pull it into BigQuery.
And so that's one thing.
And then if you have
some of the data--
we have a lot of companies
that use Drive with Sheets
and all to create some
campaign information
and stuff like that, which
is like a master information.
So if it is there in
Drive, we can just
connect to it without even
pulling it into BigQuery.
So we do both federation,
which is connecting
to external sources, but also
moving data into BigQuery
easily so that we can analyze
this at scale for you.
Other than that, we
literally believe
in democratizing insights.
What we do is, if
one of the analysts
has built segmentation,
a query to go and segment
your customers into
high value, low volume,
medium value based on, let's
say, their lifetime span,
you can go in and share that
with every other analyst
within the organization using
the query sharing capability.
You can build a Data Studio.
How many of you have
tried or used Data Studio?
Ah, yeah.
If you haven't, you should
absolutely try it out.
It's absolutely free.
The second thing
is, the latest thing
that we announced
with Data Studio
is prebuilt the
gallery of reports.
For example, if you're using
AdWords for advertising,
there's prebuilt reports
in the report gallery
that shows you all
your ads spend,
analyses, and stuff like that.
But one of the things you
can do is just take that
and connect with
BigQuery to start
analyzing more
in-depth what it is,
visualize it, and share
it with your customers,
or within your
organization with folks.
One of the things people
do a lot with Data Studio
is they build those reports
and actually share it
across organizations.
So you can take a report,
share it with other people.
They can use their login to
see what is relevant to them
and stuff like that.
So a really powerful
tool, Sheets integration.
And one of the most
important things
is we have a huge partner
ecosystem that also allows
you to get data into
BigQuery and analyze it
and stuff like that.
So as I said earlier
today, in my introduction,
I was at Zulily.
I was VP of engineering
there for 3 and 1/2 years.
I built most of
the data systems.
Before that, let me
talk about Zulily.
Zulily is an online
retailer, fashion retailer.
We launched 9,000
products every day.
They lasted on the
site only for 72 hours.
So there is a sense of
urgency to come and buy stuff
because the deals go away.
It's a daily deal site.
More than 5 million
active users when I left.
That's a public number.
And then what is that?
We used to have millions
of people coming every day,
visiting the site, trying
to look for different offers
and stuff like that.
There are few things which
are really critical, right?
When you have that many people
coming and that many products
launching, it's not
a search-based site.
It's basically a personalized
discovery kind of an experience
that you would give people.
You have to show person what
is relevant at the right time,
at the right moment,
at the right price
because if you don't
do that, there's
no way of searching through the
catalog, which is so volatile.
It's not a fixed catalog system.
So one of the
things that we did,
which was collect all the
data from our catalog,
from all the different
vendors, and actually go ahead
and personalize the whole
website based on what people
were doing in past,
and leverage machine
learning for doing
a lot of that stuff.
The second thing was, we
had 500 merchants or so,
like, really large
merchant population
that was responsible for
bringing the right products in.
We had to be able to give them
right insights in real time--
which customers are buying
what kind of products,
and how do you optimize
that in real time, what
should be the right prices,
and stuff like that.
So that was there.
How do you make better
marketing decisions?
The key thing was, how do
you keep the growth on?
Within six, seven years, we were
a multibillion dollar company.
And that growth rate
was really high.
How do you get
more customers in?
How do you do
better segmentation?
Especially, reducing
your cost of acquisition
was a key priority for us.
So here is what we did
at a very high level.
It's a 10,000-foot level thing.
The first thing we
did was we realized
when we started
on the journey, we
need a single source of
truth for our customer.
So what we did was,
first we went BigQuery.
We tried a lot of different
technology options,
on premises option.
We tried open source stuff
like Hive, Hadoop clusters,
and stuff like that.
What we realized was, all of
them were not fast enough.
We needed interactive-level
analytical capability
for our analysts, right?
They're not going to sit there
for 25 minutes, 30 minutes,
fire a Hadoop query, then come
back, and then get a coffee,
come back.
It doesn't work.
They were very clear.
Our marketing analytics team
was like, no, no, no, we
need interactivity that's there.
Otherwise, it's
not going to work.
So we leverage BigQuery
for all of that.
In BigQuery, we created
some key data sets.
There's one data set which
was all about customer.
So we had all the
customers, our members
that we had-- members
are customers who
haven't bought anything yet.
Everybody had a row.
We had all the information
for them within a single row.
And it was like,
how many times have
they bought, what have they
bought, what's the total money.
All that was in a single
row that we could get.
All their activity was
in a related table,
so that means you had the user.
You had all the activity.
All the product and all
this dimensional stuff
was already there.
So that was one key thing, like
everything about your customer.
There's a lot of talk about CDPs
now, Customer Data Platforms
and stuff like that.
It's fundamentally
just a central place
with all your customer
activity information.
Once you have that, now
you can do segmentation.
You can say, hey, tell
me all the customers that
have come in last seven
days multiple times.
Tell me all the customers
that came seven multiple times
last week and haven't
come back again.
So we were able to create these
dynamic segments in BigQuery
at scale.
And that means like the analyst
team and marketing analyst
team could start creating those
and start segmenting them.
Because previously,
what we had was,
hey, we have a lot of customers,
and we send them emails,
and that is it.
Everybody gets an email
and stuff like that.
But this allowed us to
do micro segmentation
at the scale we could never do.
And so that way,
then those analysts
were able to make those
decisions, segment them,
figuring out anybody who
hadn't come last week,
should we send them an email
and remind them, or maybe
give them an offer.
Or if somebody has been coming
consistently, not buying,
should we show
different products?
Those kind of decisions were
easier to make at scale.
We had like-- when I
left it, it was more
than a petabyte scale of data,
the total data set that we had.
But we started collecting
a lot of information.
And the second thing,
as I said, we basically
collected real-time
events from the site.
As soon as people landed on
the website, all the activity
they did, what products
they were clicking on,
what products they were
buying, what products that
were going in the cart.
We collected all of
that information.
The statistics, which
is interesting--
it's actually in the case study.
When we started the project
for real-time collection,
we were collecting 50
million events in a day.
By the time I left,
we were already
at five billion events a day.
So it was an 100x increase
in number of events.
The thing is, once you start
seeing value from data,
you want more and
more collection.
And the data volume just grows.
So we went from 50 million
to 5 billion a day.
We were peaking at almost 50,000
or 35,000 to 50,000 events
a second.
But the key thing there was
getting that information
in real-time ability to
aggregate that information,
push it into the
serving platform,
like website, to go ahead
and see how many people are
watching some products.
And making decisions like
that became really easy.
And we didn't have to
worry about anything
because the scaling
of the infrastructure
was all taken care by the Cloud
infrastructure that we had.
So we basically put all that
data, leveraged Dataproc
for the cleansing
of data, making sure
that data was
ready for analysts.
And then all the data
was put into BigQuery.
Analysts had Tableau.
So they used Tableau for their
visualizations or reporting.
Some amazing reports
you'll see trend lines
about how many people
are coming last year
same day, this day, today.
What is the change?
Is it going up, down?
How many people are
ready to churn out?
Because we had a metric
on active customers.
All of that, the analyst
teams could do by themselves.
And then, of course, we
also took the same data,
the single view of customer and
their activity and all of that,
and also powered our
operation systems.
We had more than 70 APIs that
were built on top of our data
sets within BigQuery that
allowed different systems
to call in and say, hey, give me
the performance of the supplier
so we can give a better
estimation for our customers
how long it takes to
ship them and all that.
So all those kind of
things were able to do just
because of how we picked the
infrastructure, leveraging
BigQuery for a lot of
those kind of scenarios.
One of the things we launched
this week was BigQuery ML.
It's a machine learning
capability directly
inside BigQuery.
What it is is very simple.
You have marketing analysts.
They know SQL.
They had been running SQL
queries, analyzing stuff.
BigQuery ML actually
allows you to do
regression models,
like linear regression,
logistical regression, directly
inside the data warehouse.
So if you have
pulled all your data,
moved it into a data warehouse,
which is already there,
now you can write
two lines of code
to create regression
models and do things.
It's pretty interesting.
And for prediction, you just
have to say select ML.predict
and you get predictions back.
So it's as simple as
that from my experience
from an analyst's perspective.
Here are a few examples.
How may of you saw
Day 2 keynotes?
OK, Great.
You heard from 20th
Century Fox, how
they were able to go ahead and
do a linear regression to go
ahead and predict which
customers were going
to come back for "Maze Runner"
compared to all the things
that they have done in past
and different movies and all.
So that's one example.
There were a couple of other
sessions we were talking about.
But simple things like,
you want to go ahead
and do logistical regression
for classification?
Which of your customers
are high value?
Which ones of them
are going to churn?
Which ones are going to
be doing the subscription
or not taking the subscription?
All that kind of
analysis, now you
can really do it inside and
run the whole machine learning
model within seconds and do it.
One of the other
things is, we also
have our partners like Looker
and all building experiences
to bring all of this
together within it.
So that's the BigQuery ML.
We just launched it this week.
You should try it
out, see how you
can leverage that for
different marketing scenarios
that you have.
Other than that, we have a huge
portfolio for your AI and ML
capabilities.
From AutoML capability
for translation
that we launched, our
natural language, as well
as AutoML for vision,
which was already there.
Those are just great tools
for non-technical users
or developers to just move
data in, tag them, and then
start using the API as a
batch prediction to go in
and figure out what
you want to do.
Additionally, if you have
data scientists and PhDs
within your
organization, they can
do complex
neural-network-based modeling.
You can absolutely use
ML Engine, TensorFlow,
all of those things, to go ahead
and run those kind of models.
The other key thing
we also have is we
have this thing called
Advanced Solution Lab, where
we work with key
customers and partners
to work together on solving some
interesting and major problems
that you may be
facing in partnership.
So that's there.
The next thing I want to touch
upon is open source solutions.
Focusing on open source is a
key value proposition for us.
We want to make
sure all the stuff
that our customers are investing
in, it's possible for them
to leverage them not
just on our cloud,
but also on the different
environments you have.
And then containerization,
everybody
who has been using Kubernetes
or has looked at it,
it's basically one of the
fastest growing open source
projects.
It started from within Google.
We are using containers,
making it available.
I'm not going to go
in depth of this.
But in 15 years of innovation
in big data, we have been--
before Cloud was there, we
used to actually publish
all these papers and share
whatever we were learning.
Now, we are making them
available as different products
like BigQuery, Spanner,
a lot of other products.
We also have products that
provide managed open source
solutions like Dataproc.
If you have a
Hadoop environment--
how many people have
Hadoop environments
within their Hadoop
and Spark stuff?
Good.
So Dataproc has
basically managed
Hadoop and Spark in the cloud.
So you don't have to worry.
You don't need administrators.
You don't need
management capability.
Just write your scripts in
Hive or Spark, and just run it.
And we just take care
of the whole noting
of the whole machines, bringing
it down, scaling up and down,
auto scaling.
Those are all the
investments that we
are taking from our side.
And then Composer
is Airflow, which
if you need a distributed
orchestration capability,
pull data from point A, go
ahead and do segmentation,
after segmentation, move it to
AdWords, or Facebook, or GDN,
and then go do
something else, and send
an email, that kind
of orchestration
you can do in Airflow
pretty easily.
Other than that, some of you
must have seen the Istio demo
yesterday.
Pretty cool stuff.
That's what we are doing from
an open source perspective--
Istio, Kubernetes, TensorFlow
again, for machine learning
is all open source
from our side.
As I said earlier,
one of the key
differentiators we have is
our global presence and reach.
Now, basically, if you
look at our global network,
this is the network that is
powering the billions of users
that we go ahead
provide solutions for.
It's the same
network we are making
available for our customers.
It's basically, you can locate
services closer to your user.
Imagine YouTube being watched
in all the different countries,
how close we need to
be to those users.
That's the same network
that we leverage for GCP.
It's highly available.
And then, of course, choose
your resources and locations
wherever you are.
If you want to go
ahead and regionalize
stuff because of data locality
and all, we provide that.
If you look at our
infrastructure and reach,
we have hundreds of thousands
of miles of cables, fiber optic
cables.
We actually have submarines
that actually put down
all these cables to oceans
and stuff like that.
So it's pretty cool.
We now are actually
in 15 regions.
There are six more
coming in 2018.
But we had 15 regions,
55 zones already.
So imagine the whole scale
that we are putting together.
With that, I would like
to call upon my next guest
to talk more.
IKKIN AHN: Thank you.
Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
So yeah, we build
scalable ad tech SM
to handle global
traffic within two years
thanks to Google infrastructure.
So what does our scalability
mean to start-up like us?
We started as a two co-founder
star-up three years ago.
And for the first year,
actually, we moved seven times.
And now, we started this
year with 20 team members.
Now, we are actually
reaching to 50 team members.
And we are supporting
enterprise customers
with more than 10,000 employees.
So throughout our journey, we
always use our infrastructure
on top of Google Cloud.
So no matter we have two team
members, 50 team members,
or supporting 10,000 employees,
Google infrastructure
was able to handle
the scalability.
So this is an
overview of Moloco.
We are a mobile ad tech company.
And our vision of turning
your first-party data
into the ad performance
in a secure and safe way
to give you full
control over your data.
For the last two years, we
onboarded more than 60 clients.
Our goal for the last two
years is testing our machine
learning algorithm on
different countries
and different protocols.
So we are now
running our campaign
on 40 different countries,
vertical from mobile comers,
ride sharing, food delivery,
to all different kinds
of on demand apps.
So whenever we meet
new clients, we
are very excited about
talking to new clients.
A lot of start-ups turning their
idea into directory services.
And then don't worry about
the service scalability
anymore because all that work
is backed by cloud computing.
Right?
But when we talk
to the companies,
where they actually
are stuck at is
all our company has
paid for the growth
and for their monetization need.
And the reason why is-- we
will cover this in next slide.
But complexity to build mobile
marketing and monetization
platform is becoming
more complex.
So Google, as we covered
in the previous slide,
our goal and Google's goal is to
support your need in a fast way
so your cost and business
growth cannot be slowed down.
So our goal is delivering
best modern technology
within our core.
So this is what we did
for the last two years.
We now handle more than
600 case out in QPS.
This is actually 60 billion
daily forecasts per day.
So what 60 billion
forecast mean is,
let's say you build
some messenger services.
With 100 million people, if they
text 600 times text per day,
that's 60 billion per day.
So this system is
built basically
in a scale over some
largest scale measurement
system in our country.
So we manage this kind of a
scale of services with nine
infrastructure team members.
And on our data pipelines, we
run 200 different data flow
jobs on behalf of our customers
on different verticals.
And we handle more than 100
terabytes of data per day,
with 4,000 vCPUs.
So why we build this system?
We are at a complexity over
modern ad tech and marketing
tech system.
So in old desktop [INAUDIBLE],,
what does a ad serving system
mean?
It's basically a
content delivery system.
You can put your imagery on
your content delivery services.
And you can put a simple
counter on your web pages.
You can count impressions.
And if your client asks,
you can just clicks.
But now, actually, your
marketing department,
or your advertiser,
they want to optimize
for the post-click,
post-installation events, which
is happening on advertisers'
domain, while advertisers act.
So now, you don't actually
need just to serve that,
but also, you need to ingest
the data from your advertiser,
your clients.
So now you need not only
the DSP services, but also
data installation services.
In the meantime,
you got to analyze
ALTB, cost of acquisition cost.
That needs a lot of Bigdata
system, which is the DMP.
And also, you need to
support internal analytics
groups, for which you need the
Analytics, all the players.
So now, we are in
the third day of GCP.
You probably had about a ton of
different data infrastructure
from Spanner, Cloud
Services, MemSQL, Bigtable.
So what should you use?
That's what we kind
of tried to figure out
for the last two years.
So each module, each
icon here, is actually
turning into the proper
Google Cloud infrastructure.
For example, on our
server's infrastructure,
we use Kubernetes, and the GCE.
And for the DMP, we
actually realized
that Bigtable is the most
fastest and scalable way
to support large scale
ad infrastructure.
For the analytics,
we use BigQuery.
And for the Bigdata
pipeline, yes, we
tried several
different solutions.
We realized that
Dataflow is the best one.
And at the last, the
brain part, smartest,
how to optimize to
add performance,
how to deliver the
better revenue,
and better cost optimization
for your marketing needs
is actually machine learning.
And we decided to
use TensorFlow.
We will actually cover more
on this one in our last slide.
So yeah, this
actually showed that
the complexity of the building
modern ad architecture.
And we actually
figured it out what
is the best solution for
this one with Google.
And now you can use this system
to launch your ad platform
or marketing platform
within three months.
Another interesting
observation we
realized when we
talk to our customer
is consolidation
of the marketing
world in global manner.
So previously, when you
run advertising campaigns,
what does it mean?
You normally call
agencies, right?
And hey, can you put our ads
next to 101, or this newspaper?
So let's say you go to
a different country.
Let's say you are
expanding to Japan.
You normally talk to some
big agencies like [INAUDIBLE]
or some traditional agencies.
But what we find very
interesting is, now,
actually, the top
tech companies,
they are consolidating their ad
planning team and ad execution
team in one location, or only
[INAUDIBLE] a regional areas.
So for example, one of the
largest video streaming
company, they run all
advertising campaign
from Los Gatos.
One of the largest
home sharing company,
they run all the campaign from
San Francisco and Singapore
to cover APAC and global.
The reason why is marketing is
not just about the page views
or publications.
It's all about the big data.
It's become very hard to
duplicate your big data
team for every country.
So that's why, actually,
they are consolidating
their marketing big
data team and execution
team in a few countries.
So now, actually, given that,
your infrastructure server
system has got to
support global traffic.
So the question is now,
some of ad exchanges.
For example, we not
only partner with Google
Cloud, we also partner
Google AdX exchanges.
They have multiple ad exchange
servers across the world
to cover the global traffic.
Some of the smaller
ad exchanges,
they only have services in US.
Some of the local ad exchanges,
they have a server in Japan,
in Singapore.
To figure it out where
they are, and to connect,
and to design your
infrastructure
for this the global set-up is
also time wasting because this
is not rocket science.
This should not be the
focus of your business.
But it is easy to waste your
six months, or one year.
Now, on the mobile
side, you've also
got to integrate with all the
mobile measurement companies.
I mean, in previous [INAUDIBLE]
nowadays as [INAUDIBLE]..
So some of them have
servers all in US.
Some of them have in Japan.
Some of them have a particular
location in a global location,
again, to figure it out.
We don't want you to waste time
on this kind of [INAUDIBLE]..
So we actually
figured out everything
and Google infrastructure
support on this global scales.
For example, we ran
our Bigtable instances
in four different
locations in the world.
And we ran our machine learning
TensorFlow engine in US only.
So we actually run some
of the big data pipelines
through Dataflow in four
different locations.
We actually send
intermediate data
to actually save the network
traffic costs between the data
centers and the [INAUDIBLE]
or the machine learning jobs
from the US, and then distribute
the [INAUDIBLE] of the machine
learning [INAUDIBLE]
to the other locations.
And the last, the most
exciting and important part
is the machine learning,
how to turn your data
into the real performance.
So as Sudhir covered in the
previous session, Google,
the benefit is, you
can cover end-to end.
What does end-to-end
mean, right?
So you have great services.
Your service chain
at the logo data.
And basically, the logo data
is a feedback from your users.
Now, you got to turn that
data into the actionable items
through the machine learning.
And then, the
actionable items should
be reflected to your services.
Now, you users react
to the new system.
And then they will give
another feedback, so
this kind of feedback loop.
So your business successes
depends on how you fastly
iterate this system.
And we build all this end-to-end
iteration feedback system
on top of Google
data infrastructure.
So for the global collections,
user profile stories,
we use the Pub/Sub and Bigtable.
And then we use Dataflow
to extract the data
from those data pipelines.
And we feed that data
into the TensorFlow.
So when you first begin,
yes, two years ago,
TensorFlow was early.
And then we were also small.
So we started up
from our site key
like a traditional
machine learning system.
And now, as everyone
knows, you got
to switch to the
deep learning system.
So the benefit of the TensorFlow
and the Google infrastructure
is, TensorFlow, a
lot of people think,
oh, it's image recognition,
or it's deep learning.
It's not.
It also supports all
the traditional models.
So we used to run different
models on different machine
learning infrastructure.
Now with the
TensorFlow, we actually
run all the traditional logistic
regression models, and also
the newest deep learning models.
And sometimes we mix those
two models, hybrid models.
We test all different kind of
models on top of TensorFlow.
And we compare the result
of these different models
through the A/B test platform.
And we run it in
different vertical,
in different data genre.
Sometimes, it's even like a
traditional model works better.
So still, our serving
system can support
all these different
kinds of server model
for different class need without
any other extra infrastructure
cost.
And on top of the
variants of this model,
the most exciting part is
not only the model, but also
underlying physical layer.
So we started from the
CPU-based training.
We are using GPU.
And most exciting
stuff is now Google
is launching a specialized
processor for the TensorFlow
unit, GPU.
So we can test also
these different kinds
of physical infrastructure
without then changing
any of our infrastructure.
And the result?
We achieve three times
better cost savings
or revenue per user base
in many of our clients.
So to wrap up, we grew
tremendously for the last two
years without worrying any
of the server infrastructure,
or spending a lot of money
for the dev-ops team.
We hope you can grow with
Google like that, of course.
And we are very excited about
the new end-to-end machine
learning infrastructure.
So what we like about
Google is Google's vision
on the scalability and,
also, on the global.
But on top of that,
what we actually
really like about Google
is their philosophy
on the openness.
It actually really
resonates to our philosophy
on keeping your data
under full control on you.
And how to value
your first-party data
using this kind
of new technology,
that's actually
what our vision is.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]